j'ai ressenti une présence derrière moi
qui m'a touché l'épaule et franchement
ça m'a vraiment glacé le sang
[Musique]
je m'appelle Walid j'habite dans le 92 à
Fontenay-aux-Roses dans une petite cité
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
mon histoire une histoire qui se passe
dans le bâtiment 100 alors c'est une
personne qui est morte il y a de cela
quatre ans il se passe beaucoup de
phénomènes après sa mort dans son
appartement il y a des bruits de chaises
des choses qui bougent on se demande
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui habitent
et des fois il y a des phénomènes qui se
passent dans les appartements des
voisins il peut avoir une télé qui
s'allume télé qui s'étend et des
phénomènes comme ça qui se passent moi
récemment j'avais un portrait avec
c'était un cadre chez moi accroché au
mur il est tombé comme ça d'un coup
alors qu'il était bien accroché et vitre
par terre etc alors ma mère a vécu des
choses des télés qui s'allument qui
s'éteignent la radio qui s'allume comme
ça alors qu'on sait pas du tout d'où ça
vient sinon on entend des bruits dans la
cuisine la nuit après les voisins des
couverts des choses qui bougent
l'appartement juste en face ils l'ont
scellé il y a plus personne qui habite
et il a l'appartement bas du défunt ils
l'ont pas encore scellé mais comme je
vous ai dit encore tous ces habits tous
ces vêtements etc j'ai pris des images à
l'intérieur de l'appartement franchement
quand je suis rentré j'ai vraiment
ressenti
quelque chose une présence vraiment
voilà quoi déjà il pratique et des
choses des rituels ou des du magnétisme
donc ça veut dire que il avait un
contact
je ne sais quoi avec les esprits et
quand il est mort bah il y a eu des
phénomènes
des portes qui se claquent la cage
d'escalier qui sont pas bon une odeur
très nauséabonde des on a même entendu
des cris des cris d'enfants alors moi
j'ai eu bah j'ai pas eu une expérience
qui m'a fait vraiment vraiment peur
c'est à dire que quand je rentrais tard
le soir je l'ai raconté surtout pas mon
poste il y avait j'ai ressenti une
présence derrière moi qui m'a touché
l'épaule et franchement ça m'a vraiment
glacé le sang il y avait beaucoup de
d'aviations etc par rapport aux gens qui
disaient bon eux ils cherchent qu'être
logé j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait un
fantôme dans toute la France comme c'est
retourne en Afrique etc c'était propos
un peu voilà quoi c'est
c'est bête mais
ils y croient pas et moi je les
comprends parce que voilà quoi c'est
normal mais faut être là pour y croire
et on a reçu aussi beaucoup d'avis
positifs comme des gens qui croient et
qui nous soutiennent etc et il y a eu
une personne un bon je la connaissais
pas parce que moi j'étais pas là mais
elle est venue demander après moi etc
dans l'immeuble etc et elle est à la
dormi avec sa fille dans sa voiture pour
m'attendre pour voir je ne sais pas
pourquoi et
elle a filmé quelque chose dans le
bâtiment elle a filmé quelque chose et
elle a dit qu'il y avait des qu'il y
avait des mains elle a vu quelque chose
dans la vidéo etc et cette personne là
on la retrouve pas on sait pas où elle
est on sait pas qui c'est et
une autre personne
elle est venue dans le bâtiment et
provenait de Melun elle est venue dans
le bâtiment et elle était en pleurs dans
le bâtiment et on lui demande madame qui
vous êtes etc dit je ne sais pas je me
suis retrouvé ici je ne sais pas comment
etc il y a pleuré c'était une personne
de Me l'embaume me lance c'est vraiment
vraiment loin de chez nous du 92 et
c'est des choses que je trouve vraiment
bizarres le maire nous a soutenu et a
pris l'affaire au sérieux ce qui nous a
donné bah il a donné rendez-vous à
toutes les familles après que je sois
passé sur TPMP et il a essayé de trouver
une solution maintenant le maire il a
fait de son mieux il pouvait pas faire
autre chose parce que nous reloger c'est
c'est hausser l'habitat c'est pas le
meilleur le maire il cherche de passer
les les dossiers et après il peut plus
rien faire mais en tout cas il a pris
les choses au sérieux et il nous a
beaucoup aidés c'était après que je
passe sur TPMP il y avait une femme et
un homme qui avait motif je savais pas
ce que c'était mon c'était une ficelle
avec un pendentif ils essayaient de
faire quelque chose dans le bâtiment
mais après
tous les habitants du bâtiment ils en
avaient marre tous les jours des
journalistes des gens qui veulent juste
être curieux des gens qui filment
océan c'est au fur et à mesure du temps
mais ces deux personnes là ils ont dit
qu'ils ont ressenti quelque chose
entre le troisième étage et le premier
étage bon le deuxième étage si on veut
pas de souci là moi ça me dérangerait
pas de rester 10 ans de plus
mais voilà c'est vraiment ça qui pose
problème à tous les habitants et ils
sont vraiment vraiment touchés par les
phénomènes et après si les gens ne
croient pas et je les invite à passer
une soirée au deuxième étage dans
l'appartement du défunt